- So you've done,
I just found out,
is it 19 Hallmark movies?
- Yeah.
- [Kelly] That's crazy!
(audience applauds)
That's a lot of work!
You must love working with them!
- I love working with them.
- [Kelly] It's a good team.
- You know, I've been in the
business since I was seven
so I've been doing this a long time
and I've worked with a
lot of different people,
a lot of great people,
but they very much what the values
that their movies emulate,
they are like that as a
company and as people.
- I love that.
- And I'm so thankful
to work alongside them.
They've become friends.
- [Kelly] So Christmas in Rome, right?
It's your eighth holiday
Hallmark film, right?
- My eighth Countdown-
- [Kelly] Your eighth one!
- To Christmas movie.
- That's amazing!
- Yeah, yeah!
- Did you love it?
Is this a good one?
- [Lacey] I loved it!
- Okay.
- [Lacey] It's such a fun one.
We try to make each one
different and special
and while the messages
are all very similar,
this one was particularly fun
because I get to go to Rome
and my character lives
there and she's a tour guide
and it's her passion to show
people this beautiful city
in a way that they've
never seen it before.
So she encounters Sam Page plays Oliver.
Wonderful actor.
And he's there on a business trip
and doesn't really plan
on seeing the city,
so it's her missions to show
him what Rome is really about,
what's at the heart of it.
- [Kelly] Oh I love it!
- Yeah.
- [Kelly] She's passionate about it.
- [Lacey] And they're amazing.
- Do you love Christmas?
Is that why you're in eight films?
- I love Christmas.
- We said it in sync!
(audience applauds)
(laughs)
- [Kelly] But it was crazy.
We were in unison.
- [Lacey] I love Christmas.
- Me too.
- I love it.
I love decorating for Christmas early.
- [Kelly] Me too.
- Although like total confession
because I've been busy
making these movies,
I gotta up my game again.
I kind of have dropped the ball.
- [Kelly] Girl I've wrapped
75% of our presents already.
- [Lacey] Have you really?
- Not a joke.
I don't play.
(audience claps)
I don't have any time off.
(laughs)
So when I do I've got
Christmas music going
wrapping in my dining
room like a crazy person!
- [Lacey] I love it!
And I love your Christmas music!
- [Kelly] Oh thank you!
- Yes!
- I'm a real fan.
- [Kelly] I love Christmas music!
(audience claps)
Oh my God, I'm with you.
So what's Christmas like
at the McGraw house?
- Well should we confess?
- [Kelly] Yes!
- We--
- Yes.
- [Dr. Phil] When it comes
to that time of year--
- If you say you don't like
Christmas I'm gonna smack you.
- [Dr. Phil] No, listen.
- [Mrs. McGraw] Oh no.
- Tell me if I'm lying,
we record every Hallmark
Christmas movie every year
and watch every one of them.
- Oh my gosh!
- I'm serious!
We've watched every
movie you've ever made.
- [Lacey] Are you serious?
- Yes.
- [Dr. Phil] No I'm serious.
- I'm so flattered.
- [Mrs. McGraw] More than once.
- [Dr. Phil] I think we've
still got like 30 of them
recorded on our DVR.
- Yes!
It's a tradition!
- [Dr. Phil] We bing watch them.
We've seen every one of your movies.
(laughs)
- [Kelly] Yes!
- [Lacey] I'm so flattered!
Thank you!
- [Lacey] That's so nice!
- We love them!